my beautiful friends I would like to
introduce you to Christian Grey Oh No
we started this book club to stimulate
our minds from what I hear this book is
quite stimulating that's not mine I've
never seen that look before
honestly this is nasty have you ever
been spanked huh
this book has got me in a total tizzy
come into zip-ties are you thinking
about tying me up what nothing is just
did for our age were meant to have sex
go I wouldn't do what he does to our
bodies speak for yourself
well that was not God that was doctor
nazaria you just need to put your stuff
out there judge - yes
what if you love life with these tips do
you need anything else you're on the man
of your dreams
it's just a click away no I don't I'm
fine thank you yep
slim Arthur mine what's it been 40 years
since when do you eat ice cream I got a
brain freeze here give that to a
professional God it's the first day so
put on something sexy just be
comfortable that's too comfortable right
well hey I love I'm an offense
[Music]
everybody remembers their first kiss how
about I tell you about my best kiss
maybe that hasn't happened yet
I never thought I'd be back here again
is it as good as you remember
maybe better
[Music]
you need to be a little bit realistic
there's a man out there who makes me
feel things that I didn't think we're
still possible you want a better at this
than you think
maybe things with us will go bust but
that's like and I'm not through living
Minds just yet
[Music]
I can't believe you put viagra in my
beer need you to step out of the vehicle
I don't think that's a good idea of sir
[Music]
okay enjoy your night
you too thank you
[Music]
you